this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague and
ramsey personality george campbell as we
take your calls this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
toll free number triple eight eight two
five
five two two five of course we'll take
your money questions and uh with me
being here with george he's gonna he's
gonna lead out on the money questions
and i'll help you with some of your work
questions work doesn't have to be a
four-letter word what if you could make
george the income that you desire and
also the impact how would that feel
that's quite the proposition ken you
actually know how it feels yeah i've got
there and it was kind of an accident and
now reading your content i'm like oh
now you just gave me the secret sauce i
could have done this a lot faster yeah
yeah with a lot less frustration that's
right so uh we're here together to take
your calls and and let me just tell you
something you're a toll-free call away
from some clarity
which will give you confidence whether
it's the money question or again like i
said we'll talk about some work stuff
george and i will team up on all that
stuff you got a a toxic boss uh you got
some leadership issues you're facing uh
all those questions
it's open season triple eight eight two
five five two two five so let's get it
started uh we're gonna go to salt lake
city utah to get it going with brayton
braden how can we help
yeah hey guys uh thanks taking my call i
had a quick question for you
um so we're on baby step six uh my wife
unfortunately her mom passed away a
couple years ago and
um there's a little bit of apparent
money that is going to be paid out to
her for the next four years and i guess
the short of it is we're wondering
should it should would it better serve
us in our family to put it towards
the house it's our last debt or
um
put it in into retirement and invest it
great question how old are you guys
so i'm 29 and she's 27.
29 and 27 and you guys were on baby step
six on your own you guys did some work
here yeah
yeah we well we're
long-time listeners my
my dad's ingrained in me since financial
peace babies that's what we call them we
love to hear that that's amazing man i
love to hear young people who are
getting a hold of this stuff because ken
you get this a lot man i wish i knew
this stuff when i was younger yeah yeah
oh they've got it and so you guys are
sharp already and so if i'm in your
shoes and ken you can jump in here but
baby step six you're paying off the
house you've got the inheritance how
much money is this are we talking here
well it's it's gonna be
fifty thousand total she'll get paid
twelve thousand five hundred for a year
that's just how they decided to get out
so for four years she'll get that amount
got it how much do you owe on the house
220.
okay
yeah i would go ahead and and pay down
the house with that i mean you guys are
already investing 15
right of your household income into
retirement yeah yeah well we just got a
little bit of a pay raise so
we will be yes okay um
shortly i'd definitely make that your a1
to make sure you're getting that 15 and
at that point as long as you're
maintaining that 15
any extra money on top of that i want
thrown at the house because you do have
a big mortgage there and this is going
to help it's going to give you a little
bit of momentum to to get that thing
paid off and you guys are young i would
say with this inheritance coming in plus
your incomes
you could probably get this thing paid
off in the next what five years maybe
yeah we were hoping because we were
making extra payments already we're
hoping to get it done in like the next
seven to eight years
okay
well hopefully this inheritance helps
you do it faster than that
yeah
well that's that's what we were
wondering we were just talking last
night so absolutely yeah you got it
george is absolutely right uh this is
this is money that uh you know it's
unfortunate uh by which you come by it
uh but the 12-5 coming in every month
george i would literally do a transfer
just you know you know just drop it
right on the house don't even think
about it that's going to fast forward
everything it makes you feel like we can
actually get this done and so yeah i i
do think it's an unfortunate
circumstance but this is a blessing too
with what they've left your wife with
and so you know use it wisely and you
guys have already done really well your
financial peace babies you've you've
learned this stuff early on so i have no
question you're going to do fine in
retirement i'm not worried about that i
want to get rid of this payment so you
can attack your other financial goals
love it all right let's go to middletown
new jersey where kevin joins us kevin
how can we help
hey thanks for having me guys i just
finished my lunch of rice and beans so
thank you
were they red beans were they white
beans
oh black beans george i'm a big black
bean fan we need the recipes you know
people are wandering out there
what's your question
in the rice yes um so i'm a 31 year old
broke
doctor and
before
so i have quite a bit of student loans
um
about 220 000
of student loans right now um but
i
moved back to my parents house when i
moved back to new jersey before covet
then that struck so i just kind of fell
into sort of a safe place for a little
while until things started to look
better
in my current job situation now things
are looking better
and
i make about 90 000
per year right now
and i'm hoping to grow that but not
change my current job situation because
i appreciate it so much
so what i was i want to move out of my
parents house i was hope like i've had
bad roommate experiences in the past but
i understand the financial benefits of
having roommates but at the same time
i'm also thinking about
creating a youtube channel
and create some passive income that way
and use that one bedroom apartment for
sort of a multi-purpose studio to do
those things
i was just wondering is that a good idea
would you guys
uh
call me stupid for thinking that or
is that logical i'm not going to call
you stupid that's dave's job and he's
not in the office today so here's what i
will say there's a part career question
which i want ken to answer because
there's a lot going on here uh you
wanting to start the youtube channel but
you're a doctor but you're broke but
you're concerned about moving out and
getting roommates
i i like the idea of you moving out and
i do like the idea of you getting
roommates because it will remind you
that you are broke when you get your own
apartment you really think you made it
right you go man i gotta i got a youtube
channel i got my own apartment i am
living and i want you to keep living on
beans and rice
so on the financial side i think uh can
you afford to move out of your parents
house i think on 90k income you can get
an apartment uh in the new jersey area
with a roommate and afford it uh just
fine on the career side i want ken to
speak to this because the youtube
channel part i'm interested by because i
think there's better ways as a doctor to
make more money yeah i i uh we only got
about a minute so you gotta give me a 20
second answer what's the youtube channel
going to be about
it's going to be like an exercise
library of corrective exercise and
tips and techniques to help get you out
of pain great i absolutely would do that
and make that a labor of love it'll take
your mind off of eating rice and beans
all the time because you are in that
zone right now and i applaud you
i think george is absolutely right move
out that's going to give you some
personal mojo getting out of mom and
dad's house you can't afford it stay
with it uh but understand this about the
youtube channel this is not for the
faint of heart you got to do it every
day every day every day stay with it
come up with a rhythm study people that
are doing what you want to do well on
youtube steal like an artist it's a
wonderful little book you should get
from austin cleon yeah i think you
should do it if we can monetize it every
nickel
goes to paying off the debt you got this
kevin hang in there man
your best days are still ahead he's
george campbell i'm ken coleman and this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
that's
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
i'm ken coleman i'm joined in studio
this hour by my colleague george
campbell it's a range of personality and
uh
he is the host of the fine print podcast
this is the latest uh of the amazing
shows that come out of ramsey solutions
part of the ramsey network and uh this
is how you learn about the latest money
traps and trends think of george as like
your consumer advocate is you're
knowledgeable of course about the baby
steps about ready to be on baby steps
seven i'm told what do we have an
estimated uh we're shooting for april
2022. so not far away
for house really excited and tell people
how old you are 32 years old 32. but if
you see him in real life he looks like
he's 13. thank you wait i thought i
thought that was going to be a
compliment it turned out to be i'm not
sure what that was okay but you're good
skin care that's what it's all about can
you know that well you got a great beard
thank you i couldn't grow that kind of a
beard
turning it around with the compliments
yeah you got to do what's happening you
got to do it no uh you know what listen
it's the reality is i'm in my 40s and
and i see a youngster like you and i go
man time flies i look at myself like a
young ken coleman oh thank you very much
george uh so the fine pin prime cap find
print podcast rather
and this is a wonderful wonderful show
it's only 20 minutes long so they get to
a lot of stuff there
some of the episode titles how turbo tax
is screwing you wow george uh taking it
to pg-13 right not fooling around can
people getting hurt out there yeah it's
now the worst time to buy a house could
bitcoin be your ticket to wealth i mean
there's all kinds of great stuff here
wonderful stuff go check it out search
the fine print podcast wherever you
listen to podcast uh and check that out
all right uh does it feel like
no matter what you try or how how hard
you work you just can't get ahead with
money i know that feeling i've been
there before so is george but you don't
have to live like that if you're sick
and tired of being sick and tired today
is the day to decide you're going to do
something different financial peace
university is the step-by-step plan
that's helped nearly 6 million people
pay off debt and take control their
money combine that with the premium
version of
every dollar the world's greatest
budgeting tool and you will make
progress right away and it's only
available with a membership to ramsey
plus
everybody's got a plus now george you
got to have it and so of course ramsay
plus is our plus today is the day you
can decide to break cycle living
paycheck to paycheck this month only
we're taking 30 off the price of a 12
month membership to ramsey plus start
your free trial of ramsey plus today
by texting trial
to 33789 that's 336
all right the phones are open triple
eight eight two five five two two five i
could talk to you about your work
moving up the ladder george that's
called a bigger shovel stage five of my
seven stages to doing what you were born
to do is get promoted now let me tell
you something george
if you're gonna get promoted you're
probably moving into leadership some of
you're going i want to get promoted i
don't know if i'm ready we can talk
about all that so
you got a phone call around that area of
course your money questions the phone
lines are open triple eight eight two
five
five two two five paula is up next in
greensboro north carolina paula how can
we help
hi there i'm actually calling to tell
you how
dave ramsey made my life a better place
awesome what happened
about 2003 my husband and i moved into a
house we built and
we were always nervous about his job
being eliminated he worked for a
manufacturing firm
and about
i don't know maybe it was 2005 it all
kind of runs together
he introduced me to the dave ramsey show
long story short
we ended up paying off the house
we had this house custom built
and we took the big shovel that i had at
work
and we paid off the house so we've been
debt free for a while
how much was that house
uh we we paid
we mortgaged about 125 000 wow
because we'd already paid a lot down on
it what's that house worth now do you
think oh gosh i think we've um
that was in what did i say 2005-ish
and um so now i think it's um another 75
000 more nice that's awesome so what's
the key people are listening and you
start listening to show and you just
start getting gazelle intense and i'm
sure if dave were here he'd say well he
didn't do anything you did it you and
your husband did it we were scared about
his job and we just didn't want to have
to worry right so
and and long story short we didn't have
to worry my job which was had the big
shovel was eliminated about 2011. wow
and
i took the severance and threw that in
the bank and we've got a good financial
guy that helps
helps us and helps teach us
and
so now we're at 2013
i'm diagnosed with multiple sclerosis oh
no
but we don't have any debt
so when i leave that job
and go on disability
then we only have to keep the lights on
and because we had taken the money that
we'd earned in the big shovel that i had
and we didn't have any debt
we were able to put that money in
investments and have that um
money ready and waiting when my husband
was able to retire at 57. wow
in 2020 right in the middle of the
the virus
so not only did we not suffer so our
version of living like nobody else so
you can live like nobody else looks like
this
i go from a six-figure income to
disability
my husband retires at 57.
we're living in a paid for house
my husband and i are living
off of the
interest and much less
because it you can do that because you
don't have the debt you can be
at home and retired at 55 and 57 years
old that is amazing paula we are so
proud of you and george you know you
hear a story like this and by the way
she's just laying it out yeah
testimonial after testimony on their
journey if you see
what would normally be a massive crisis
for somebody it's not a crisis even so
she's got some physical challenges you
can tell it's not holding her back i
didn't hear stress in her voice at all i
felt a beautiful calm demeanor it was
very relaxing i could have listened to
her all day long i know so great yeah
she's like let me tell you one other
thing yes i'm here for it paula way to
go you guys are crushing it and you're
just proof that this plan works for
anyone and a lot of people think they're
special ken and they go well it's not
for me you don't understand my situation
look at paula's situation they overcame
a lot of obstacles and they decided to
give themselves some options yeah
instead of tie themselves down to debt
because everyone knows you got to have a
mortgage payment don't you ken yeah well
no you don't you don't absolutely you
don't let me tell you something in
today's real estate market
i mean imagine how some people are
cashing out and still have
room left over to do something i mean
it's just amazing what's going on right
now and that is a major real estate
asset you know just your not just your
home
but i mean it's it's an amazing
situation in their situation they've got
a lot of financial options and still
relatively young george i know you can't
picture this but 57 is not old you got a
lot i mean people are living to be a
hundred ken with all that i don't know
health care these days and we're
learning some things i'm hoping to live
to a hundred are you really that's my
goal well you can be [ __ ] at 100
you're a very clean eater that's i'm
gluten free guys that's the key
anti-inflammatory diet
there's uh is that because you choose to
or because you have to you know it is an
intolerance but it's also a choice yeah
i love that by the way kelly kelly's i'm
looking in the control room kelly's and
i are the exact same age so i can't tell
you how old i am today because you get
mad at me don't say that i was going to
spell the beans but like only a
millennial kelly would say that it's an
intolerance like just the way you say
that you know what i mean so but uh
george i'm glad you're taking care of
yourself thank you um but but you're a
guy who's on the edge of this deal too
and you're going
i'm hoping to pay my house off in about
six months or less
what does that feel like right now
you're not there yet but that's gonna be
pretty amazing for you yeah i you know
what it is ken it's once you once you
really set big goals for yourself the
house payoff just becomes a a part it's
a milestone it's not the even the end
game it's just we're going to celebrate
it and then we're going to go okay
what's what's our next big thing and you
do that when you get on the same page
with your spouse who by the way she
works here yeah we met here ramsay
solutions we've been married almost
three years now and she was more intense
than i was and once you have that kind
of fire you just start to dream you
start to go what would life look like if
we didn't have any payments in the world
what would we do and that will keep you
going for the rest of your life gotta
have a vision
love the call paula i'm so proud of you
thank you i know you encouraged
so many people please pass along george
and i's high fives to your hubs the best
is yet to be
and uh you know what else is to be more
of your calls coming up don't move this
is the ramsey
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
national headquarters still to have you
with us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague george campbell we're taking
your calls this hour it is a free phone
call what are you waiting on triple
eight eight two five
five two two five we'll take your
questions about your money your life
your work are you working on purpose
george you know this i'm crazy
passionate about helping people discover
what they were born to do because
there's just more to work
than just a job and a paycheck and so if
you've got questions about moving you're
going i'm in the baby steps can i change
jobs can i make a transition while in
the baby steps the answer is yes i'll
tell you how to do it in fact
if anything i'm trying to help you do
that so you can get a bigger shovel and
get out of debt faster so we'll take
those calls as well let's get it started
off this segment with jonathan who joins
us in louisville kentucky jonathan how
can we help
hey good afternoon gentlemen how y'all
doing today we are living the dream
what's going on glad to hear it okay so
this is my situation so
i'm trying to get everything in order i
bought a house last october um the first
year is coming up so i'm trying to get
everything squared away with the 15-year
plan to have it paid off
but i still have a little bit of debt i
have about eight thousand dollars that i
owe on my car
and i have about
six thousand dollars in credit card debt
so i'm thinking about just paying it all
off so i can just focus on my house and
i'm just i don't know if that's a smart
move or not because i don't want to
you know if i need an escape vote for my
safe for my savings i don't want to you
know put myself in a twist at the end of
the day
put yourself in a twist i like that turn
of phrase jonathan well let me start
with this do you know the baby steps
that we teach
yes
so we teach you to first have that
thousand dollar starter emergency fund
and then tackle the debt then get that
fully funded emergency fund and then we
move to 3b where we save for the house
so it sounds like maybe there was some
things done out of order here and that's
okay we can clean this mess up but how
much do you have in savings
about 35 000. 35 000
yes how much of that is your actual
emergency fund how much do you need for
three to six months of expenses
uh give or take
five six thousand
total for your three to six months
emergency fund yes oh yes like like six
seven thousand yes well that leaves us
with some really good news if you have
35k in there and you only need seven for
the emergency fund you can pay off all
your debts hold on a second george
uh jonathan
are you telling me that three months
expenses is seven thousand dollars for
you
yes oh my mortgage is yes okay i just
wanted to make sure that yeah not three
months i'm sorry about about four about
four to five months about four to five
seven thousand and three months more
like four to five months okay uh there's
so something's still not adding up so
your monthly expenses are about what
twelve hundred dollars what are you
running with the mortgage and everything
to keep the lights on feed yourself
13.50 for the mortgage uh about another
what is it about
about another grand for
the expenses for the house so 246.
yeah that's about right yeah that's
about right six seven thousand dollars
oh so you're saying six or seven per
month
for expenses yeah okay so we need to
multiply that out to 10 times three to
get to three to six months of expenses
so the answer to the question uh is 21
000 minimum jonathan
that's what you're doing
which is perfect because you just told
me you've got 14 000 in debt and you
need 21 for the emergency fund so to me
you make the calls as soon as you're off
the phone with us you go pay off that
credit card you go pay off that car loan
which is going to free up a whole bunch
of money for you to actually pay off
this house in 15 years or less does that
sound right gotcha it does yes okay and
i want to make sure you're also
investing 15 of your income into
retirement have you begun that
i have but i'm not doing 15 i'm at 10
right now and then with the uh with the
401k 10 percent in that as well so okay
normally i'd tell you to pause the
investing but because you're going to
pay off this debt today i'm not
concerned with that what i want you to
do though is before you start attacking
the house pay off all this debt today
increase that investing to 15
of your household income total into a
good retirement account depending on
your situation maybe an ira or uh 401k
roth if you've got either those options
and then whatever margin is left over
throw at the house and pay this thing
off i think you can do it in less than
10 years you seem like a hard working
guy
definitely but i mean i make you know
seventy thousand dollars a year i feel
like i can afford it it's just hard to
let i guess let go of the money you know
i mean that's a lot of money so it's
just kind of hard to let it go oh i get
it but you know what what else is hard
looking at those payments disappear from
your bank account every month instead of
going to you to your goals so i think
you've got a few things backwards we got
so much going for you jonathan and i
want you to do things in order that's
what we teach is the baby steps so pay
off all this debt today clean this mess
up get to 15 and then you'll be paying
off that house with total freedom and no
payments in the world yeah it's gonna
feel so much better jonathan you just
gotta focus on the big picture not the
immediate and so what happens is george
somebody's got a lot of money in his
case 35 000 in the bank right and so the
immediate focus it's just kind of like
tunnel thinking oh man it's 35 000. i
don't want to cut a check today for 14
grand and watch that drop to 21 or
whatever it's emotional it is emotional
but the big picture is wait a second
let's get outside of that a bank account
and go what does this do when i pay off
this debt
how it fast forwards everything he's
making good money now he's through baby
step four and now he's just rocking yeah
and people don't understand the momentum
that you get when you do the steps in
order because you're jonathan you're
trying to do a lot at once right now
you're trying to pay off the debt you're
trying to invest you're trying to pay
off the house and what happens is you
lose steam because you go i can't do it
none of it's really moving i'm not
moving the needle so once you start
doing this stuff in order you're going
to gain a ton of traction and you've got
a great income to get that done yeah
really good stuff there thank you so
much for the call let's go to matthew
now in oh louisville it's louisville day
we're going from louisville to
louisville uh matthew now joins us
matthew how can we help
hey ken thanks for taking my call guys
um i lost my job a few months ago and um
that's that's all right i think i think
you would have told me it was toxic
anyway but
um
so i i've been in manufacturing like
ever since i've been working which has
been about 10 years
and um
so i i feel like this is a time for me
to to do a career
pivot i guess i did take your career
assessment oh good and and i was uh
i i believe that it was pretty spot on
um what did it tell you
what where is it leading you
it's
to me it's leading to protective
services and maybe law enforcement
interesting is that something you've
wondered about in the past
honestly ken it's it's something that
i've always wanted to do yep and so you
took the get clear career assessment
when you read your purpose statement it
pointed right at that the purpose
statement i would have to find it
no no no i'm not making you read it but
the point is is you took it and you're
like wow this this confirmed a lot for
me
yes sir all right then so what's your
question because it sounds like to me
this is something you've always wanted
to do and now you're clear that law
enforcement protective services is
something you were born to do it allows
you to use your talent
to perform your passion to accomplish
your mission so what's the question
well so the prof hiring process
takes a while time time consuming yes
sir yeah so in between um i'm having a
hard time i've i've had a few interviews
for um different manufacturing jobs and
stuff
and um i just
i won't get any i'll get denied
and then i'll find out the next day that
they're still looking for for new work
or whatever and i'm like man what's
wrong with me how come they couldn't
take me so i don't know if there's if
i'm going in there i'm trying to go in
there as best you know as i possibly can
but i don't know if i'm going in there
and there's a chip on my shoulder
because i have a hard time wanting to go
to another factory to
even if it's
another thing is whenever i get into
something like a job i don't i hardly
ever quit it yeah well now here's the
deal though okay so let me just tell you
what's going on i think you do have a
chip but i think it's coming out because
you just i self-identified it but here's
the deal all you've got to do whether
it's another manufacturing job or not
you have got to go take care of yourself
in the short term so that you stay
afloat and you're stable
while you move into the qualifying
process of getting into a local police
department or sheriff's department
because those process even if it's on
the federal level uh you know this you
just set it those take a while so right
now your whole mindset needs to change
you need to take the chip off the
shoulder if you got to go to
manufacturing or go work in some other
day job it's a day job it's only to keep
you stable
while you move into the dream job that's
the great news matthew you know what you
want to do you know why you want to do
it you know how to do it so here's the
deal shake the tree
shake the relationship tree go get a gig
go in with a great attitude
and you're gonna quit it when you get
qualified
and you get started and walk right into
that law enforcement job thank you so
much for your heart thank you for the
service that you want to do for your
fellow man you got this all right george
we got to take a quick break but we're
not going anywhere your phone calls next
on the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you're joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman and i'm joined in studio the
shower by my colleague george campbell
uh the uh
well i guess it's the latest the newest
personality and greatest sure i'll throw
that i'll take it yeah you're fantastic
yeah we we weirdly hit number one in the
business space on apple podcast on our
launch week which was a huge honor so
thank you to all of you who have
downloaded shared it told your friends
print podcast we just released a new
episode what is it this is a good one
after pay affirm klarna should you buy
now pay later that's what it's all about
uh and this is a big trend we're seeing
across
every single website you can buy things
right under the add to cart button
there's a hey we can take the price down
by 75 percent if you make four easy
payments remember those old commercials
yeah of course so this is the modern
version of installment
payment plans and tons of people are
falling for it ken because you go wait i
got 200 in my car they're saying i can
just pay 50 today wow which means i can
add more to my cart and this is only a
20 minute show 24 minutes we have 24.
yes so this particular show is 24
minutes we interview
nathan hamilton from the ascend which is
from the motley fool and they did a
survey with 1800 people digging into buy
now pay later uh turns out 38 percent of
people are using it to make purchases
they can't afford shocker oh boy right
so this is a great show you need to
download this uh subscribe wherever
podcasts uh are available and i want to
mention really quick my brand new book
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love it unpacks the
seven stages that will lead you to doing
what you were born to do making the
income you desire and the impact uh it's
available for pre-sale right now ramsey
solutions for only twenty dollars you
get the book from paycheck to purpose
plus the audiobook the e-book and over a
hundred dollars of amazing goodies and
then we have a a bundle there
that for only thirty dollars you'll get
the brand new get clear career
assessment that our last caller just
talked about and that's gonna give you
tremendous clarity it's like the compass
and then the it shows you the mountain
this is the this is the dream and then
the book is the guide up the mountain so
you can get um the bundle or
just a special price on the pre-order
the book comes out november 9th go to
ramsey solutions dot-com all right
pre-ordering i'm doing are you gonna do
that you read the audiobook too i
haven't done it yet
oh it's great fun that's worth the price
of admission alone i love i love a good
audiobook and i love following along
with the book so that's why i love these
bonuses because i have the physical book
and then you're reading it to me oh so
you're one of those guys i'm one of
those guys it helps me stay focused
fascinating yeah yeah really interesting
i'm pumped about this book ken
truthfully i think what total money
makeover did for people's financial
lives this book from paycheck to purpose
is going to do that for people's careers
we certainly hope so um there's just so
many people that are moving on this year
the great resignation they're calling it
and i think it's really the great search
for purpose so we we think we're hitting
the wave at the right time all right
let's get to the phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
phone number let's go to
west palm beach florida where heather
joins us heather how can we help
hey how are you we are living the dream
heather what's going on
i love it um so i
got myself into a bit of a pickle uh
years ago did a debt reduction program
oh cool it sounds like a great idea you
pay off part of my credit cards not
knowing they were going to kill my
credit and what was going to go on with
that
um so i've been working with a program
uh to
deal with the credit creditors and all
of it and uh i'm just not sure where to
go from here i'm like i
i guess i'll leave it at that
well uh
you being in a pickle heather there's a
way out of this and the the key is to
stop focusing on the credit score so let
me ask you this
why do you need your credit score to be
higher
i'd like to buy a house buy property and
i don't know i'm looking to
get married and i don't know that if it
will influence
anything in our relationship moving
forward hold on you're saying you're
you're future you have you have a fiance
a boyfriend
i do
okay and you're saying hey this guy's
not going to marry me if i have a low
credit score
no i'm not saying that at all i i want
to take personal responsibility for it
and i don't want anything related to
that to negatively implement them well
the best thing you can do uh for your
future for your marriage for buying this
house is to get rid of all the debt you
have and what happens when you do that
and i experienced this myself when i
first started working here at ramsey and
paid my debt off is that your credit
score doesn't go to zero it's impossible
well what happens is it becomes
indeterminable
it's a ten dollar word that means it
disappears you're basically invisible to
to the credit bureaus so how much debt
do you have
heather are you with us
that truth just shocked her into
oblivion oh we'll see if we can get her
back so heather will give her one more
shot heather heather heather
disappeared she went invisible ken look
at that i think i spoke it into
existence that would be really creepy
yeah or she fainted well i think the
idea that her credit score would
literally disappear into the ether i
think she fainted it was too much yeah
well uh if she's still listening let me
let me finish what yeah play this out
because okay let's say she does that
like you did so here's the thing people
go i got to get my credit score up and
i'm going to work with these programs
and debt reduction and most of these are
scams and like like heather found out it
just tanked her score it's not super
helpful and so what is helpful is taking
control of your own situation and
cleaning up the mess that's really the
only way to do it there's no magic wand
they can go here's an 800 credit score
overnight and so what i want you to do
heather is pay off all of this debt and
your credit score will soon be
indeterminable after a little while
and then you can do what's called manual
underwriting or a no score loan when it
comes to getting a house so what that is
is like the olden days ken uh not that
you're old enough to remember this but
back in the day they didn't have credit
scores to look at to give you a mortgage
so what they looked at was your actual
financial situation right and they went
wow you've got an income you've got a
steady job you pay your bills on time
your utility bills your rent whatever it
is and they go all right here's a
mortgage so on that front heather you're
going to be just fine and i can tell you
that because i went through this exact
process not having a credit all right so
here's the good news uh heather is back
with us we hope heather are you there
i'm here did you faint
um maybe i don't know
some technology somewhere was like she
doesn't she can't hear the influence
in the wiring all right so george take
over so heather how much debt do you
have
uh so
i feel like i can't even fully answer
that um where the debt was at when the
program started and then it went up i i
couldn't tell you what the totals is
well that's a1 we've got to figure out
how much money you owe if we're gonna
pay this thing off so i mean can you
give me a ballpark
uh i think the one might be uh nine
grand and the other might be at like
3500 so total of that is say let's
eyeball it and say 13. yeah okay and how
much what's your income
um
my income is about 45 a year
okay
and here's what i want you to do i don't
know how soon you're going to get
married but i want you to start cleaning
up this debt on your own no more
programs stop looking for a solution
outside of yourself you are the solution
and that's some really really good news
and like i was saying to ken earlier
when we lost you there
once you start paying off your debt your
credit score is going to become
indeterminable meaning you're invisible
to the credit bureaus and i'm not
worried about the house because we we've
got great partners like churchill
mortgage there's a ton of mortgage
companies out there that will do this
thing called manual underwriting or a no
score loan where they just look at your
real financial picture and they go all
right heather has a real income she's
got a steady job she pays her bills on
time we're going to give her this loan
and i want you to do it in the ramsey
parameters
of a 15-year fixed rate mortgage that is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay uh
so once you do that you have a healthy
down payment and you know you're
probably been married by then is is
something i imagine and so you're going
to have what we call dual income which
is a beautiful thinking you've got some
a bit a lot of power double income no
kids is where we start making major
major problems huge heather here's the
deal here listen heather um
relative to the amount of money you make
and the debt you have you can get out of
this really really quick so
i appreciate the call but you don't need
to be worried about your credit score
you want to get out of debt and this is
going to set you on a great path for the
future that george just so beautifully
described so you got this kiddo i mean
my goodness this is just about getting
out of debt i mean 13 000 in debt for
somebody that's single making thousand
dollars you pick up a side job and you
get your budget and uh hang on the line
let's get her and ramsay plus i love
that let's give her a free trial to
ramsey plus kelly because what you need
to get control of your money she's not
even sure how much she actually makes
here's your first problem so let's go
look at the pay stub and go here's my
gross here's my net now i know what i'm
actually working with i can go exactly
into the budget ramsay plus is going to
get you started it's going to set you
free good stuff hey i want to thank my
colleague george campbell for hanging
out i want to thank our producer ben
hill and our associate producer and call
screener
kelly daniel hey i also want to thank
you america because we do the show
for you this is the rainbow
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsay show it's where america
hangs out have a conversation about your
life your money your work your
relationships
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell we're here together this
hour to take your phone calls triple
eight
two five it's 825-5225 free number
triple eight eight two five
five two two five thrilled to be with
you today and i know some of you out
there listening going all right
i uh i've listened i've got a question i
need a little bit of breakthrough i need
a little bit of encouragement i need a
little bit of i got a b or c which way
do i go
well george and i are here to help you
george will take your money questions
and i'll specifically help you on your
work questions are you doing what you
love are you doing what you were called
to do do you think it's possible to make
the impact and the income
that
you want at the same time
if you don't
i beg to differ give me a call let's see
if we can help you get on the same page
it is possible george life is too short
to work for the weekend and by the way
you can work the baby steps and my seven
stages to doing what you
love what you were born to do it's
possible as a matter of fact
stage five of my seven stages is get
promoted by the way that usually comes
with a pay bump and that'll make that
shovel bigger so george and i are gonna
lock arms today and we're gonna help you
out triple eight eight two five five two
two five let's go to spokane washington
to start us off the shower justin joins
us justin how can we help
oh yeah uh thanks for having me um
my wife and i
just entered into contract to sell our
home and
we're kind of curious if
maybe doing like a hard reset on our
total debt uh would be a good idea at
this time because we will be making
enough on the sale that we could wipe
everything that we have in debt whoa
justin
uh now before george dives in what do
you mean we could uh you're assuming
that are you saying the contract may or
may not go through and what do you mean
by that
uh i mean i'm just
we're definitely going to make enough we
made enough on the sale that we could
pay off we have about 88 000 combined
debt with
vehicles campers student loans things
like that okay great
um and we're
we'll walk away with about 118k from the
sale all right
what what caused you guys to sell
um just uh trying to
the financial freedom um we're gonna
move in with my mother-in-law for a
while and
uh we were gonna pay off whatever we
couldn't after the
home sold but the market was crazy
enough that it was kind of like strike
while the iron's hot how long are you
going to be with mom-in-law
um
we planned for a year
if it goes beyond that that's fine we're
remodeling her basement for separate
living
how old are you guys
we're in our 30s
okay and this would be a temporary stop
gap for a year
until what
well we would like to buy some land
um
and then develop the land uh outside of
town where
we're looking at land currently but not
sure if it's the right time to do that
or not
so once you buy the land you still got
to wait and build so i what i don't want
is for this to to be a two three year
thing accidentally which happens more
often uh than you'd think and so i i
don't want you guys uh taking up space
in the basement for too long i love the
idea of you taking the proceeds and
getting rid of the debt you said you've
got 118 k coming in from the house sale
and you have 88 in debt
correct okay so that means you'd have 30
left over uh do you guys have any money
outside of that that's liquid and
savings or an emergency fund
we've got just uh just a few thousand in
savings that's about it we had just
started doing it that snowball
we applied a lot of our stimulus money
towards debts to start chipping away at
it
okay well i like this idea of this thing
just being napalm and just destroying
this debt instantly having 30k left over
plus some savings which will uh be i'm
guessing more than enough for your fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses is that right
i i would think so we haven't even made
it that far as uh as far as planning
that goes
well start to get this stuff on paper
but you're about to leapfrog in the baby
steps which is always uh great news when
you can just fast forward this thing
because of this home payoff so what i
want you guys to do is start saving up a
real healthy down payment once you have
that emergency fund in place figure out
what that looks like for you guys based
on property and land i just know that
when you deal with land it's probably
going to be a longer journey and so
maybe you get into something
while you get the land and get this
house built but i don't like the idea of
just this thing being sitting out there
and you're living in the basement for
too long
right yeah that makes sense justin i'm
curious uh prior to selling the house
how much were you putting a month
towards your debt
our debt snowball uh i think we hit
about 850 a month that we were throwing
on top of our
smallest deck okay that's huge i just
want to point this out uh george just
said this but i wanted to be very
specific you take that 850
on top of the 30 000. so the 30 000 is
going to get the emergency fund i think
fully funded i feel pretty good about
that and then um and now you got 850 a
month that's going to be that's going to
add up pretty quickly as it relates to
getting the down payment and that's on
top of all the money that you're going
to free up by paying off this debt
how much is that are just all the
payments collectively
oh goodness i'm not sure yeah
i really don't know that answer it
i want you to figure that out a little
out of control yeah i want you to figure
that out because it's going to encourage
you when you go oh my gosh we were
paying 1300 on debt plus our 850 we were
throwing on there that's 21.50 we could
put every month towards this down
payment and then it feels possible and
that's what i want you to feel is that
this is not a pipe dream and hey we're
just going to live in the basement and
figure it out as time goes on i want you
to have a plan on paper of your exit
strategy yeah and once you have that
everyone's going to feel good about the
situation because things are going to be
clear yeah and what's your household
income
well we're just about 95 000. okay
yeah yeah yeah i think i think this is a
great move uh i'm really excited for you
i'm with george um
you know one year could pretty i mean
it's going to take them a little bit of
time to save up and then if they're
talking about buying land to develop so
i just you better come up with a backup
plan besides living in mother-in-law
space yeah because this is going to take
a few years to save up to develop the
land that's going to take some time what
i like is though they have this house
payment freed up too on top of the debt
payments freed up on top of the money
they were put on the snow yeah they
could make some serious pile of money
here if they stay focused and don't just
go spending and going hey we're rich no
yeah so what's your what's your personal
uh length of uh time you could live in
your mother-in-law's basement i don't
want to answer in case she's listening
ken but uh
okay all right you can't back out of
this i would i would give it a year i'd
say 12 months is my maximum before i go
i want my own space and like you said
earlier in a car even if you're saving a
ton of money even if yeah i think
there's something that it does to your
spirit when it's on you yeah
and i want that for everyone i don't
know that i could live in a renovated
space while i was living and renovating
the same time i think it was a real
challenge for me personally i know you
can throw it in the basement of my
mother-in-law and i love my
mother-in-law yeah uh i i don't know six
months man i think that's my max okay
just me personally i believe it yeah i
think so too you gotta own it
that could get tricky you know what i
mean
something to leave and cleave those
marital vows it rhymes yeah it does on
purpose all right folks don't move more
of the ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching to pure top just go
to feartalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america i'm kent coleman he
is george campbell and you're listening
to the ramsay show so thrilled to have
you with us triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
it's toll free triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we're taking your
calls about money we're taking your
calls about your work you want to get a
bigger shovel and move up the ladder to
actually do work you love well i'll take
those calls for you then george of
course is going to help you out on your
money calls and uh we'll team up on some
stuff too so let's go scranton pa oh i
love this uh it's great every time i see
scrambling pa i think the office these
poor people they're like it was
long before that yeah you know what i
mean so we won't mention it directly but
there it is i've already let it out of
the bag glenn joins us glenn how can we
help
hello glenn hey how's it going well
we're living the dream
oh that's great uh if you have a ghost
uh guest i just want to say hope you
guys are having a good day and thank you
for accepting my call very kind thank
you for thinking of me glenn yeah george
is with me
okay
and anyways i'm uh i'm a 23 year old
over-the-road truck driver i've been
doing it for two years since i was 21.
and in that time
i
have been able to pay eleven thousand
dollars cash on uh
uh
we have twenty thousand dollars in the
bank
i make about 60 000 a year
i have zero debt
and i am living with my parents whenever
i
take some time off i go over there and
enjoy you know
whatever we do up there around scranton
and basically i've been reading this
book called
the richest man in babylon and
it basically says
that
in order to become financially wealthy
you need to save your money and invest
your money and i'm just wondering
if you guys have any recommendations
absolutely great book dave actually
wrote the forward on one of the
additions that that we sell here ramsey
solutions that's awesome you've done
really well so are you 23 now how old
are you
yeah i just turned 23 on the 14.
and you've got no payments in the world
and 20 000 in the bank am i hearing that
right
yes i like this so far we're doing great
because if you know the baby steps that
puts you uh past baby step three where
you've got no payments no consumer debt
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund and i imagine twenty thousand
dollars is more than a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses for you correct since you don't
have many expenses
right yeah i only have a hundred and
fifty dollar phone bill and a 250 dollar
auto insurance
wow so you're living at 400 a month
right now for expenses
plus food right yep
okay well that's great plus food
well plus food i guess you could say
probably uh two to three hundred a month
okay well the key here is you've got
real low expenses you have a great
income and you're really young and
you're already doing this stuff so
here's what i want to tell you you're a
baby step four where you invest 15 of
your household income into retirement so
what options do you have right now for
retirement do you have anything through
work like a 401k
um i will have one next year fantastic
eligible for one next year well in the
meantime because you have earned income
you can open up a roth ira and you can
fund that with six thousand dollars uh
for your 2021 contribution limit so if
you've got that money and you've got
that leftover in your bank you can go
fund that today
okay what is that actually i never heard
of that so the ira it's the individual
retirement arrangement and it's it's
basically a shell that keeps the
government uh the government's hands off
your money
so what you're going to do with the roth
ira is inside of that you're going to
choose mutual funds and if you need help
with this definitely connect with one of
our smart investor pros that are in your
area you can do that at
ramseysolutions.com these are the vetted
trusted pros that can help walk with
this uh walk you through this and
educate you because we tell people don't
just do stuff because i told you better
ken told you about it do it because you
know it's the best decision for you and
so these guys and these men and women
can walk you through those decisions of
how to set up that roth ira what to
invest in
uh based on the ramsey parameters and
good growth stock mutual funds but
you're 23 you're going to be a
multi-millionaire if you start doing
this stuff now which you absolutely are
so outside of the roth ira once you've
funded that six thousand dollars you can
start to invest in that 401k through
your workplace and just make sure that
the total amount is 15 of your household
income going into those types of
accounts your roth ira a 401k or a roth
401k if you have one and that's going to
grow tax free with your after tax
dollars so way to go he's doing really
great yeah absolutely fantastic
absolutely love that hey george
blinds.com uh has a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color which by the way i would i mean
it's made for the ken colemans of the
world who will do that they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from eric in virginia
have a 26 year old son
with a degree in global affairs who has
been looking for work over the last year
with no success he has sent out many
resumes but his experience
is a slim
oh okay it says written wrong wow his
experience is slim having only worked in
customer service at a grocery store no
one is willing to give him a chance he
wants to go back to school to get a
different degree to increase his chances
but i'm not sure that will help what
advice
can i give him okay well couple things
we've got a degree in global affairs
all right and i am admittedly as i
answer this question not a big expert on
the global affairs degrees
but obviously that tends to lean towards
government or certainly international
business would open up a lot of
opportunities potentially there
but the resumes have been going out he's
been sending a lot of resumes
and he's only got at some point in his
young working career george he's worked
in customer service at a grocery store
all right mom first of all there's
somebody who's willing to give himself a
chance but i teach that a resume without
a relationship is almost worthless now
what i mean by that is
if you're just submitting resumes in
2021
they're just piling up digitally like
there are many times that you're going
through one or two phases of the uh
application process where humans not
even looking at your resume because of
the artificial intelligence and the
software so
what we've got to do is we've got to say
okay wait a second if i've got this
degree in global affairs and i want to
work in either international business or
government we got to first establish
what does the young man want to do is
does he have any ideas that he wants to
pursue that are attached to his degree
if in fact that he does now we're
looking at all right it's ken coleman's
proximity principle and here's how it
works george you know this wrote an
entire book on it became a bestseller i
believe it's somewhere here in the
studio there it is over to my left it
doesn't look fantastic george
bookshelf here's what it says in order
to do
what
i want to do fill in the blank you've
got to be around people that are doing
it and in places where it's happening
now there's some major depth right there
right there's no there's no depth it's
actually super you unpacked it uh in the
book with a lot of teachers here's the
deal i if i'm that young man i'm getting
around people that are in that industry
that are actually doing that work why
because i want to know hey how'd they
get in what do they love most which
particular side of things would i want
to land on the more i get information
this is where we engage the brain george
and we go okay i've got a degree in
globe affairs i thought i wanted to go
here after i went for some people
actually doing that my heart went
right and i got there some more
information i ground some other people
getting this kind of works out until our
heart goes ding ding ding right it's
pretty simple stuff
yeah i want to do i'd love to do this
all day so now we're looking okay i got
the basic degree what other additional
experience would i need to eventually do
this so then we back out of that this is
the entry level so i got to go get a
death job
at a multinational corporate just to get
in or whatever that is so that's the
process but what happens is and i feel
so bad here you gotta yeah and what's
the worst they're sitting all the way
it's essentially like chopping a tree in
the middle of the wilderness nobody
knows he's doing it and so you've gotta
ask off who do i know that knows
somebody in that industry uh who are the
people i need to be around what are the
places i need again where i could job
shadow and by joshua or volunteering
right out of the gate get a dory
drive uber and then so this is all about
effort at this point yeah and i can't
just sit here she's saying get a
different degree i don't think the
degree is the problem if you want to
work global affairs you've got to go
find yourself a job in global affairs
and start i start as an intern ken i
think he's got to start slow and work
his way up there applying without
relationship connections george is
literally like scratching the lotto
ticket it's just not a chance to pay off
all right don't move more of your calls
coming up this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague george campbell
and we're taking your calls this hour it
is a toll free number i don't know what
you're waiting on breakthrough is
one phone call away triple eight eight
two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and let's go now to
anna who joins us in miami florida and i
understand anna you're on the line to do
a debt-free scream
yeah i can how are you yes i am awesome
well that's so exciting so how much did
you pay off
i paid off 82 000
wow how long did that take
it took 23 months and 15 days wow i love
it and what was your range of income
during that time
and 95 000 to 102 000. nice now what do
you do for a living
i'm active duty military and i've been
serving for over 11 years i'm getting
ready to go to the middle east actually
oh my goodness anna well let me just say
this you are a great american thank you
for your service
you thanks for your support yes ma'am uh
all right so take us 23 months ago
what was the catalytic moment what
happened what caused you to go on this
debt-free journey
so for me right so i've been bopping
along all along i came from the
caribbean i'm jamaican so i came here in
all three and
just speed rolling through credit cards
personal loan having fleece and you know
just
all the consumer debt you could think of
and back in 2019 in june when i started
this journey
i came out here in sierra vista arizona
so i was stationed on fort huachuca
during um the two weeks almost two years
of paying off this debt and so i went to
the new i went to the id card office and
i met this guy tim and you know he told
me about financial peace university and
how you know every day every you know
the average american goes to um you know
to tennessee to do their debt free
scream and i was like uh okay what's
that he's like have you heard of dave
ramsey i'm like no i'm not
and you know so after him telling me
about the program and being so
passionate about you know everything
that you and the team does and
everything that they dave do
i left this office that day i got my new
id card because i just gotten a
promotion so i needed a new card
and i went back to my car and i was like
okay i'll go on youtube and i kid you
not i went on youtube that day i
listened to about two dead free screams
and the rest is just history i was just
fired up wired up and i just got after
it that's awesome i love that what kind
of debt was it so credit cards uh
student loan personal loans and a fleas
oh wow you had a little bit of
everything you definitely were worried
about absolutely george yeah absolutely
oh my goodness and you just went just
full throttle on this thing what kind of
things did you do what sacrifices did
you make expenses cut income what did
you actually do to get out of this debt
that fast oh yes so beans and rice rice
and beans every day all day in and out i
cut on the lifestyle i was not in
nordstrom shopping on the weekends
anymore no more eating out i cut off the
amazon
i cut off the sirius xm radio i sold
everything in my apartment i was like
literally sitting on the floor i got rid
of the couch like i sold everything wow
oh my goodness did people think you were
just nuts doing all this
yes my mom at one point was like are you
sure about this
you're like stop it mom i'm eating beans
right now i can't be bothered
on the floor absolutely sure
yeah you know i just created a plan too
and just literally went on every every
dollar app created
you know my budget which is like my
blueprint right now and i made this
wicked spreadsheet that just goes out
till i'm like 100 years old right now
i'm 34 right now but
yeah i'm i'm all in yeah yeah
you you are not you're like levels
beyond all in i don't even know that
there's a phrase that captures that kind
of amazing focus and discipline good for
you
yeah you're watching absolutely
go ahead
no you go ahead
i knew i was gonna say that i also
volunteered to become a coordinator and
i also do coaching on the side
so you know just giving back so i've
been running a lot of classes online so
i really thank all my clients and all
those are you know
so how many are so you're a financial
coach
yeah i mean yeah so i do there's a
little side hustle and going to school
and being a normal duty soldier
yeah yeah you're amazing i'm exhausted
just talking to you i mean trying to
keep up but yeah i need a nap
i'm just curious how much are you making
with your financial coaching side hustle
so on my side also right now and with my
transition going overseas i'll say on
average right now roughly about 20 to 30
k because i you know i'm doing it part
time wow that's amazing part time 20 to
30 000
yeah that's fantastic and you're leading
financial peace university classes on
top of that yeah
yeah i am can we clone you yeah i think
we need more energy in the world
absolutely i'm gonna have gifts for all
you but i wasn't able to make it up to
nashville because i'm in the process of
getting ready to go overseas but i have
coins for everyone um that's on the team
because i was a commander during this
time so i had company coins but i have
points for everyone when i get back you
are you are so cool you are
extraordinary
so
what would you say to people who maybe
just like you have only been listening
or watching the show for a small amount
of time and they're hearing this story
and they're going anna's super human
she's not even real she's like a
superhero i can't do it what would you
say to him
so you know for me
just
answer that call right and just knowing
your why of you know
why you would like to become debt free
and just living below your means you
know i was that right in the wheel just
going going spinning on my little wheels
and it doesn't work looking rich but
have zero dollars in the bank account so
i just tap into knowing my why and you
know my why it makes me cry like anthony
talks about because i i was raised in a
community where i walked like 15-20
miles to school in jamaica the roads are
bad no one has food to eat no clothes
so my wife going back and giving back to
that community in buxton jamaica where i
grew up and just providing clean water
sanitation and just a food kitchen just
everything so these people you know just
to improve people's quality of life
and just providing
dialysis machine and computers printers
community center like that's like my
biggest why of why i did this and just
really being intentional
anna you are truly amazing uh just so so
privileged to be able to listen to this
story i know it's encouraged so many
people and again i know you're getting
right ahead of the middle east to serve
our country you are you are just a great
american a great person uh you've
inspired so many people so we want to do
something for you so we're going to give
you two books we're going to send you
kelly i'll take care of you in a moment
we're going to send you a copy of the
legacy journey that's the next step um
in the process for you that's from dave
ramsey and then of course we're going to
give you a copy of dave's wildly popular
book the total money makeover for you to
gift to somebody else because you've
done it that's gonna have a lot of
impact when you hand it to somebody else
so anna here we go anna from miami
florida she paid off 82 000
in 23 months making
95 to 102 000
anna this is your moment let's hear your
debt free screen
thank god almighty three
two one i'm debt free
[Music]
she is absolutely debt free wow man i
need a nap just hearing about all the
things she's doing and is going to do i
i feel like a loser my face hurts ken
my face hurts yeah yeah she was
absolutely inspiring she was gonna she
was willing to do whatever it took to
get rid of this debt yep that is what we
call gazelle intensity she is the poster
child yeah unbelievable love love love
her story by the way ann if you can when
you get back come to nashville we'd love
to love all over you and celebrate you
uh what a wonderful wonderful lady
and serving our country by the way
praying herself in harm's way to protect
our precious liberties what a what a
fantastic story wow all right folks
don't move
good news more of your calls coming up
this is the ring to show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
ramsey show and we're thrilled to have
you with us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague george campbell george what do
we got for folks well i've got some good
news for you guys we are bringing back
the epic ten dollar sale for these last
two days of august can you believe
august is already over ken what's going
on here man well here at ramsey we think
of august as a second new year we've
noticed that once everyone's done with
all the distractions of summer they're
ready to kick things into high gear and
we all know you still have goals that
you want to reach so to help you get
back on track we are bringing back our
10 sale on our top 10 books so this is
your chance to pick up best sellers like
uh the total money makeover the graduate
survival guide was just got a new
redesign and so much more you can check
it all out at the online store at
ramseysolutions.com but you gotta hurry
because like i said this thing ends in
two days and don't forget we've also got
some cash to give away love giving away
dave's money on air that's always fun
ramsay cash giveaway ends in two days so
enter today
and tomorrow for your chance to win the
three thousand dollar grand prize that's
gonna help your baby steps no purchase
necessary must be 18 or older to win all
you have to do is text the word cash to
33789 to enter our giveaway now that's
cash to
33789 and remember 48 hours yeah and
george forgot to mention that my number
one bestseller the proximity principal
is in that list i mean my kids need new
shoes george you're right i mean
i'm working hard we're already selling
it at ten dollars ten bucks is a good
deal and i think if you get like it's a
good deal for those people free shipping
i don't know about me i love free
shipping don't you i do love goods i
can't stand paying for shipping so get
three give some to a friend yeah
especially ken's books especially yeah
because i got to put i got to feed my
kids i get three teenagers and one of
them he's a big he's a big dude he's a
big i would not take him away i now own
stock in costco it's the uh only because
the amount of food yeah yeah yeah the
499 rotisserie feeds the whole family
boy that's the truth all right folks
let's get to the phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number let's go to dallas texas ashley
joins us there ashley how can we help
hi ken and george hi um i'm a travel
nurse i'm on baby step two okay um i
have 60k left in student loans
i after looking for a year um i have my
first nurse practitioner job lined up to
start november making 100k a year
with kovitz picking back up um the rates
for a travel nurse
right now are 5k to 9k per week about
but there's no guarantee how long these
rates last
my question is should i put
accepting this job
from advancing my career to hopefully
have my student loans paid off by the
end of the year doing the traveling
i want to move forward in my career but
i see this opportunity here as well and
make sure i heard you correct uh what's
the move forward in the career what is
the is it a nurse practitioner
yes well here's the way i look at this
um
will
opportunities to be a nurse practitioner
be available at the end of this year and
beyond
yes absolutely
how much longer will these rates
these insanely amazing
rates that travel nurses are getting how
much longer is that going to be
available
no telling no telling
but fast forwarding getting out of debt
60 000 you can get out so much quicker
and still walk into a very nice job a
very nice career doing what you love if
it's me if you called to ask me what i
would do
yeah
i would take the travel nurse job and i
would just press pause on stepping into
the field because you're already
qualified you're already ready it's not
like you're delaying by getting
qualified you're ready to go but to take
this money now to pay off this debt fast
and get it done absolutely because then
you're going to come back you're going
to step into the career you love
with no debt
yeah and i'll tell you this if it were
me i'd i'd stay in it until i got the
emergency fund taken care of i'd do baby
steps two and three and then i'd walk
i i think that's exactly what
what i can do in the next three months
listen to that ashley three
months 90 days 90 days you're delaying
stepping into the work you're already
qualified for 90 days and you're going
to get debt free and put the emergency
fund in place
go yeah and ashley i just did some
napkin math for you to encourage you
here 5 to 9k a week that's what you said
right
so on the high end that's 36 000 a month
which means you'd have this debt paid
off in two months and on the low end
it's twenty thousand dollars a month
which means you pay this thing off in
three months so either way it's a good
deal it's a great deal and you're gonna
crush this thing so fast and still get
that nurse practitioner job making 100k
plus ashley this is exciting are you
ready to celebrate are you getting
excited about this
i'm very excited i think i've just also
been waiting for a job and so i i've
been leaning exactly towards what you
guys are saying um i think i just needed
that little reassurance like i can hold
it off just a little bit longer i can
because listen you're still going to be
incredibly valuable you're going to have
plenty of opportunities this is just
such a gift i'd take it and i
would want this opportunity and here it
is for me i feel like i should take it
you should you're three months away
oh ashley go i mean i'd call him right
now
like right now hang up right now column
say i'm taking it i'm in i could beat
the airport in an hour you know what i
mean like i would be that excited yeah
this is great news and my brother's a
nurse practitioner and let me tell you
the need is not going anywhere and it's
probably only going up uh and she sounds
like she's got a great head on our
shoulders and like she said she just
needed the reassurance yeah you know
well here's the thing
look
let's unpack this for a moment
for people that are that are in the baby
steps and they're in baby step two
specifically two and three where you're
trying to really get yourself stable
baby step two for new listeners that's
you're paying off all of your debt
except for your house uh and so
that's super important to set yourself
up for the future and then that
emergency fund is a wonderful wonderful
kind of nice warm blanket every night
when you go to bed because emergencies
are going to happen
when you're in those two stages it's
really really critical that you have a
temporary mindset to get that but to
realize that you're not going to be
behind in your professional career you
may have to delay some things
but it doesn't mean that in the grand
scheme of things george that the dream
is dead that you can't get there
and many times you can still pursue and
be getting qualified you know while
you're paying off debt so yeah i think
sometimes there's a hurdle for people
and in her situation she's going i've
wanted this nurse practitioner job for a
long time i've got an opportunity but
now i got this other thing it's like oh
what do i do debt or dream debt or dream
and it's like whoa whoa whoa it's not
that's a false narrative
it's not debt or dream it's
debt
and the dream it's just they're not
happening the exact same time i love
that mentality and i i do think you're
right a lot of people see it as i'm
taking a step back or i'm i'm going over
here i need to be going in this
direction and the baby steps is
propelling you forward when you do it
the right way you're never gonna feel
like man i really screwed up by paying
off my debt we don't get calls like that
no and it's only going to help your
career well and let's look at it this
way when she steps into that nurse
practitioner job yes she's going to step
into it a little later than
she had originally envisioned
but you're stepping into it way better
so is it later yes or is it better it's
both you're going to step in later but
it's going to be better and stepping in
debt free that's my practitioner better
game changer life's better yeah so
therefore the job's better when i don't
have that hanging over my head now let's
let's let's run the opposite where a lot
of people want to get there quick
so let's say that she would recall and
she goes all right i'm what do i do she
goes well i got this opportunity to be a
travel nurse and knock this dead out in
three months but i've worked so hard
i've waited so long to be a nurse
practitioner i'm going to step into that
well stepping into that with
all that debt
now you can't truly enjoy this gig as
much as you would be able to enjoy it if
you didn't have the burden of debt
hanging around your neck yeah that's the
point
so there is something about us humans
george you know this
that we want everything as fast as we
can possibly get it's in the human
condition to want progress and to want
it now but sometimes you just have to be
patient and i got to tell you patience
is hard oh yeah and you know ken as i've
really thought about this i've been here
eight years now and i found a common
thread with almost everyone who gets
into a pickle
and it's a shortcut
that's what debt is debt is just a
shortcut where they go you know what i
could get there faster if it wasn't my
money if i just borrowed it i could get
there faster if i just was a little bit
lacks and did this over here and it's
when you do the hard work that sacrifice
the gazelle intensity that we talk about
all the time on the show that you
actually feel progress and like you said
it's temporary a lot of people think
well dave doesn't want me to eat out
that's not what it is dave wants you to
eat out as much as you want and you can
do that when you don't have any payments
in the world that's so true don't even
have to worry about that all right good
stuff hey george campbell always fun to
be with you my friend hey i want to
thank our producer ben hill our
associate producer kelly daniel and you
america thank you so much for joining us
you can do this
there is a clear path of baby steps work
time and time again
it's been a great hour
this issue
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out
talk about life to talk about your money
to talk about
your work purpose relationships
mental emotional health hey we're just
talking about you because you matter
deeply i'm ken coleman i'm joined by my
colleague george camel and we are
together to take your calls this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five george i don't
know if you can tell my voice a little
raspy today yeah i was wondering about
that ken you want to fill us in oh yeah
i think i'm going to i uh no allergies
i'm feeling fine
but uh went to uh see harry connick jr
last night at a local amphitheater
and he's one of your all-time favorites
he's my favorite all-time artist i just
love the guy and it was big band and we
were whooping a little bit so uh the
voice a little strange you were hooting
and hollering to every song not every
song it's not that kind of a concert
sure you know what i mean but uh you
know i love the instruments and all of
you had the trombone the cl the clarinet
the flute the sax
and the drumming solos so you know at
certain points those big bands they all
do the solos yeah so i feel like when a
when a musician is doing a solo an
instrumental solo
you know they need somebody to yell for
them because everybody yells for the
artist that's true so got a little
excited last so you're hooting and
hauling for the trombonist out there
well you know they did a lot of uh you
know new orleans style jazz oh yeah
that's got some soul and some spirit to
it and it's probably been a while since
we've heard some good live music like
that with everything going on it's great
it was outdoor the amphitheater locally
just the the rock quarry oh yeah
graystone quarry great great local venue
here yeah very good so anyway
you're feeling it i think you're not as
young as you used to be well i'm hanging
out late yeah i don't know that i need
to be whooping anymore yeah you know
what i mean but hey i'll do it for you
thank you george eight triple h eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to st george utah where scott joins
us scott how can we help
hey you guys thanks for taking my call
today you bet what's up
so my wife and i got a copy of total
money makeover several years ago now got
all excited chopped up our credit cards
and it didn't really
do anything with it from that point
until now when we took a road trip and
listened to the podcast the whole way
and we're just really recommitting now
to paying off our debts
uh so when baby step two
my question is
and he's gone just we lost him yeah gone
we totally lost him nope hold on oh he's
back there we go okay there we go hold
on we're going to get him so i can pick
him up
scotty there
scott
there we go all right so you we had a
cliffhanger so you said you said we're
paying off debt but or something like
that so pick up there
sure so we're in baby step two we're
fired up about it our question is
um so i became a realtor in march 2020
so right when covet hit
um we've been really learning how to
handle our money being self-employed
uh that's been a challenge in its own
right
um
so you know we have this possibility of
down months i mean this year i've had
months where i've made zero dollars and
i've had months where i've made tens of
thousands of dollars
so the question is
you know dave's philosophy is is put
every spare penny on debt and
aggressively tackle this debt but we
don't want to leave ourselves high and
dry in the event that you know deals
fall through or get pushed back and i
end up with a with a
barren month a zero dollar month
so i guess the question is
to put it short what should
aggressively tackling our debt look like
in our situation
so tell me this how much debt do you
have
so consumer debt we have about 63 000
and that's not including the house
which we owe
about another 236 000 on okay what kind
of debt is the 63
uh it's predominantly student loans and
payments on loans on two cars two
vehicles okay yeah i wanted to see if
there was cars there i'm wondering
are those any of those cars worth
selling could you get something cheaper
i mean what is how much of these cars
worth do you think in today's market
with it being so hot
um so i've evaluated that um i've taken
one of them to a couple dealerships and
posted it online just trying to get what
i owe out of it to try to then go back
and pay cash for
for a smaller or you know older car
um
so
i haven't been able to get a bite for
like what i owe yet as cars probably
worth a couple thousand dollars less
than what i owe on it is kind of what i
seem to be finding
um
okay yeah well let's talk about the
irregular income side because you're
saying sometimes i have zero dollars
coming in sometimes i have fifteen
thousand dollars so with that what we
say with the regular incomes first of
all you don't get a pass on doing the
budget in fact you need the budget more
than anyone because of this irregular
income so what you want to do is take
your lowest monthly estimate so on the
down month obviously you said some days
it's zero but what is reasonable maybe
you take a look back and you average it
out and say okay average month probably
looking at maybe three thousand dollars
you can use that as the baseline for
your budget and so from then you're
going to start making the priorities
right you need your four walls covered
you need to start making your payments
on you know your mortgage your rent your
utility bills food make sure you've got
your transportation taken care of
and from then on you're going to make a
list of everything else in priority of
importance and so here's what happens if
the money doesn't come in we want to
make sure we at least have your bills
paid the important ones then if you do
have money coming in we can attack the
next things on the list and so when it
comes to the debt you still need to be
doing the debt snowball listing them out
smallest to largest paying minimum
payments on everything but that smallest
debt and attacking those and if you have
a great month well you just got a great
month to attack that debt and if you
have a down month that's okay your debt
snowball is just going to look a little
bit different and it may take a little
more patience but it also means not
spending everything you made if you
brought 15 000 in that month so you
gotta focus in this budget and start
really making a plan for here's the
priorities we're gonna make sure our
bills are paid and then we're gonna go
down and pay the debts
all right good stuff there george i
appreciate that a lot of people uh they
feel like it's almost impossible
to
to process the advice we give on
irregular income because of the very
nature of you we as humans we're afraid
of the unknown so i can have a ballpark
idea but i don't know exactly what it's
going to look like what is the key to
pressing through and actually keeping
the emotions out keeping the mental kind
of obsession out of this and going hey
we can figure this out even with the
irregular income yeah well a lot of
people go well because there's unknowns
i'm just not going to make a plan
because you can't plan for the unknown
but instead what we teach and this is
part of financial peace university you
can find this inside of ramsey plus we
have the regular uh income planning
worksheet where it actually helps you
write all these down write your
priorities out to go okay if we get
extra money this month here's what it's
going towards if we don't we've got to
hunker down and make sure that our our
four walls are taken care of and so it
can be done a lot of people have
commission type jobs but you got to go
what is our baseline for what we think
is our lowest monthly estimate or
average out what was the lowest month i
had this past year yeah yeah really good
stuff oh i love it i love it i love it
all right folks uh we're just getting
warmed up okay we're just into this hour
one second here we go
it's a free phone call i don't know what
you're waiting on triple eight eight two
five five two two five he's george
campbell i'm ken coleman and this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
george camel and hey folks we really
value
the input from you the listeners of the
ramsey show it helps us know what's
important to you so we can deliver the
right content that will help you with
the questions and the challenges you
have right now one way that you can
share your thoughts with us is by
answering a few questions in a new
survey we just launched you can check
out the ramseysolutions.com
survey it's ramsey solutions.com survey
or
you can text the word survey to 33789
text awards survey to 33789 it only
takes a few minutes and there's a
hundred dollar amazon gift card up for
grabs as a thank you for your time text
the word survey to 33789 or visit
ramseysolutions.com
survey and say really nice things about
george white please do it i know it's in
there and you know i was just talking to
tim who's our director of research here
at ramsey solutions great guy and this
this survey really is about them it's
about the listeners the people listening
right now to make the show better for
them and so this is not a self-serving
thing where it's like hey say nice
things about ken although you should uh
but what it's going to do is make a
better show for you guys so make sure
you do that ramsay solutions.com
survey it's a huge help to our team and
we really appreciate your feedback we
actually make changes based on what
people have to say sometimes
occasionally don't get too carried away
well i won't be making the changes yeah
dave doesn't like that but no no
we do depends on the change
as long as we're still here and employed
i think we're we're safe yeah i think
it's good no i'm saying dave's not going
to make a change just because somebody
asked us to no you feel what i'm saying
yeah we care about you but not that much
yeah gotta be careful
let's go to dawn in williamsburg
virginia dawn how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my calls
you bet um i my question is a two-part
question uh my husband and i bought a
purchase at home in 2007 and it's been a
money pit we are constantly keep
thinking after each new repair that it's
gonna end and it just is continuing
uh we we do have a great interest rate
and so forth um but i really feel like
we're putting too much money into it
should we sell our house but more
importantly we want to stay in our
community and if there's nothing on the
market at the time for us to buy because
it's a good time for us to sell
is it okay to rent for a year is that a
financially mistake you know should we
buy maybe a cheaper house and then use
it as a rental property we're just not
quite sure how to
handle that
well there are no laws in virginia that
say you can't rent so that's we're off
to a good start here but i love your
question because a lot of people are
listening or going man i got to get into
a house and like you're saying home
ownership can be an absolute money pit
and so what i'm hearing from you is you
don't want to stay in this house you
want to get out but there's not really a
lot of great options for you right now
correct
yes okay there's a lot of rental options
out there but i heard that's a big
financial mistake no no i don't know
that is a total myth renting is not a
sin renting in this case is going to set
you up for amazing success especially as
you guys take the time to do things the
right way and get in a home you actually
love because here's what happens the
biggest financial mistake is getting to
a house that you don't like and can't
afford and so i like you guys selling
while this market's hot i mean how much
could you get for the house
about 8.75 wow and how much will you
actually net after the sale we we owe 6
30.
great on it don here's here's one thing
to be thinking about
think about how much money you've spent
on this money pit house and you just
start that's why i'm calling i know but
think about running those numbers and
you can amortize that over a 12-month
thing and look at the rent versus all
the money you've spent i just wanted to
throw that in there you're not wasting
money by getting out of this house it's
going to feel like heaven to have
someone else fix all the problems for
you won't it
absolutely so you're okay with renting
for a year until maybe you see something
that would be completely fine
yeah that's why george said that he said
that really clearly it's not a sin we're
totally okay with it when it's a
financial strategy but if you're just
renting forever when you have the
ability to buy a house and do it the
right way the way that we teach then yes
but in this situation this is you
getting out of a money pit situation and
i'll bet you if you run the numbers
you're going to come out positively
financially by renting
yeah and even if it's too much
just
i did the dave ramsey solution several
years ago and i cannot i can't recommend
it to enough people you it you it was
dead on it worked perfectly for us you
know completely out of debt or only debt
is this house yeah and it's just
fantastic so
i had to put a little plug into that
good well thank you very much here's the
deal you you need to take a deep breath
after you sell this house and relax a
little bit reset you have no debt it's
not going to be a problem for you guys
to rent take your time watch the market
look for something that feels right and
move
oh thank you so much like oh i'm so i
already felt like a weights lifted off
my shoulder yeah i can tell thank you
very much for taking the time yeah you
bet thank you so much absolutely yeah
wow that's good stuff and you know what
she's going to net just based on the
math of course there's going to be fees
but you know 240 000
sitting in a in a good you know high
yield savings account that's not going
to hurt while you're renting yeah and
maybe even adding to that because
clearly they have a great income yeah
they have great income and all those
expenses are going to go away and so
they just keep adding to that nest egg
and oh by the way they can easily afford
their rent and they're going to find a
great house that isn't a money pit yeah
no good all around brainerd all right
let's go to jackson mississippi now
george where shea joins us shea how can
we help
um hi i'm happy you took my call
i just have a question about what i
should do as far as my career i've been
in the same job for about 22 years i'm
46 years old
there's really no in this position no um
room for advancement at this point um so
i'm trying to just see should i try to
get a second job should i change careers
i don't know what
to do at this stage
what have you been doing
what industry are you in
um hospital okay so are you a nurse uh
supporter no no just awesome yeah office
okay and so you hit a lid
uh so the first question i have when you
say i have no advancement opportunities
if you were in a different hospital
different system whatever whatever
whatever and you could you had
opportunities to advance
would you be calling me
or would you be advancing
how would be advanced interesting so see
that to me is a great equalizer that's
what we need to be focusing so is it
really a new career or is it a different
place to the point that would you when i
say this i want you to tell me how this
feels are you doing the right thing in
the wrong place
um see that is another thing why i
really don't know what i do um i do it
with it maybe because i've done it for
so long
so what would be up the ladder for you
what would advancement be give me a
position
or a title that you're aware of that you
can't get to where you are currently
um probably director
of a director of the department yeah do
you love leading people the concept at
least the idea of like leading and
serving people
yes yeah see that's a leadership
position and so that's you know if you
want to lead people that's not just
uh exclusive to the health industry
uh okay you know what i mean so let's
have some fun really quick because i
think you have some ideas but you're
afraid to say it because it's like how
do i get there do i need education so
let's have some fun just for a moment
and i want you to answer this question
with your heart not your head you got it
okay all right first thing that comes to
the top of your mind and we let our
heart just say it we don't cancel
anything out if you could try anything
tomorrow
you knew you could not fail
but you didn't have to commit to it for
the rest of your working life what would
you do
oh
um
say it because while i said that your
brain was running
what came to your mind say it
wellness coaching wellness coaching
interesting so here's what i think i
think you need to
go do your homework on what it takes to
get qualified to be a wellness coach
how much can a wellness coach make where
would a wellness coach work could they
work for somebody else or is it a
a cell phone business
that's the homework that i want you to
do now when you get the homework on that
you see what it's going to take then ask
yourself if i changed
positions
in a different hospital system and moved
up and made more money in that day job
leading people
well
could i then get qualified faster and
start my wellness coaching on the side
shea
that's what you need to be looking into
and you need to figure out how to get
there because that's what she wants to
do george absolutely it's amazing how
just digging in with a few questions can
change everything well you got to take
away all the limits then the answer pops
right to the top of her heart she didn't
want to say it but then she said it good
stuff shay thank you for the call
don't move more ramsay show coming up
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show america
i'm ken coleman joined by my ramsey
personality colleague
george campbell we're having a blast
today the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to hartford
connecticut where michael joins us on
the line michael how can we help
good afternoon i
am running into a wonderful situation
but it's difficult
two years ago or right before
2020
me and my wife bought a new house
and um that was a great thing because it
gave us more room to run around for our
three little boys and um
now we're discovering that windows are
leaking and the car is breaking down and
bodies are breaking down
and i don't want to go back into debt to
take care of these huge ticket items
because that's what we did before
um we're on baby step two we've already
uh paid off all of our debts but i just
don't want to go
i mean the only thing left is our house
and i don't want to go oh let's get a
new car and
and finance that i was like no we need
to stop that
hold on hold on hold on a second
are you getting pressure from somebody
else
are you feeling the temptation yourself
to go buy a car
we would like to have
a good car
we don't want the one that we have to
break down and then
we're stuck getting a new car then we
want to we want to be proactive at
getting something that will
continue we'll not need to
need as much maintenance yeah i
understand you didn't answer my question
you i i heard you say we on that second
one but the way i'm just saying what's
really going on right now
you're going i'm worried that i'm going
to go backwards
or we're going to go backwards when we
pay this off and i don't feel like
that's coming from you am i right or am
i wrong if i'm wrong tell me
uh
it's partially me and
partially my wife as well all right
so i'm hearing uh you're trying to do a
lot of things at once i feel like and we
just took a call about how home
ownership is a money pit and so you're
just helping my point here uh michael
and obviously you know the baby steps
home ownership if you don't own a home
already would come in baby step 3b when
you don't have any debt and you have a
fully funded emergency fund and this
situation is exactly why because when
you have the mortgage and you've got
home repairs and you have the debt and
you don't have a fully funded emergency
fund life gets stressful and i can hear
that in your voice so let's talk about
the numbers here what's your income
uh we're looking at 85 000 a year
okay and how much debt
uh zero debt except for the house
oh see that's the other thing george he
said he's got the baby steps you need to
give him a refresher on the babies i
just got real confused because you told
me you're in baby step two and keep and
and things keep going wrong but baby
step two is where we pay off all of our
consumer debt except the house you have
not a payment in the world except your
mortgage
correct no car payments no credit cards
nothing
nothing okay and do you have a fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses
yes
it's but it's not um
like it doesn't have
any like
designation like i remember hearing from
dave ramsey that everything every dollar
has a has a job to do
well that's in your budget attached to
it i'm talking about your emergency fund
which is
separate that should be in a separate
savings account do you have that okay
uh i think it's all in one
one big savings account okay so here's
here's what i want you to do
go open today if you don't already have
one open a savings account where you
park three to six months of expenses so
i want you to add up what are the what
are the bare bones things we need to
cover the four walls the utility bills
the rent to put food on the table for
for your wife and the boys what are
those expenses multiply that by three to
six months depending on your situation
and how volatile it is if your wife's
not working and you're the only source
of income well then we want to increase
that to six months if you have a regular
income let's increase that to six months
and uh how much liquid cash do you have
right now in the bank account
uh probably about ten thousand
okay so it sounds like we have a start
here to the emergency fund we just need
to pile on top of that and here's what's
going to happen here's why i'm honing in
on this emergency fund but once you have
that you're gonna have a lot less
emergencies number one it's amazing how
that happens ken once you get this
foundation you you know dave talks about
this all the time you start having less
emergencies once you have a solid
financial foundation because you start
going oh we could cash flow that out of
our budget we can move some things
around and not even touch the emergency
fund but right now what you're saying is
all these home repairs are causing
stress because we're worried about
having to pay all of it but you just
told me you don't have any payments
except for the mortgage is this mortgage
taking up a large chunk of your world
how much is the mortgage every month
uh mortgage is only like uh 600
600 bucks 600 800 bucks a month yeah
okay so bottom line is george
listen uh mike
you're not going to have a problem
fixing the car if the car breaks down
you're just not
so you've got it's like the monsters
under the bed but there's no monster
under the bed am i right or are we
missing something because your whole
thing is i'm tempted we're tempted to go
into debt and buy a car because the car
we have we're afraid is going to break
down but if the car breaks down you've
got the money in the emergency fund and
probably in your monthly budget to be
able to absorb that true or false
i think you do all right then so there's
no monster under the bed yeah
yeah i think what you need to do here is
get that fully funded emergency fund
three to six months put in a separate
savings account that you do not touch
until
unless it's a legitimate emergency try
to cash flow it otherwise and once you
do that you've got to start investing
are you guys investing right now
yes
okay well that i want you to pause that
if it's going to take you more than a
month or two to get this emergency fund
in place but you need to be investing 15
percent of your household income into uh
good retirement accounts and once you do
that then we can start looking at paying
off the mortgage and saving up for the
kids college and all that kind of stuff
but we got to get the solid foundation
in place you've got to do the baby steps
in order and what that's going to do is
give you this thing called financial
peace that we talk a lot about on this
show where you're not worried if the car
breaks down because you can fix it
you're not worried if you've got a leaky
roof because you can fix it with the
emergency fund it takes the drama out of
life
so you've got this michael you've just
got to start doing this stuff in order
and if you need more info you can just
google dave ramsey baby steps and we'll
get you taken care of thanks for the
call michael let's go to baltimore
maryland now where ricardo joins us
ricardo how can we help
hey y'all how are y'all doing today
we're living the dream man what's up
amazing uh so yeah i wanted some advice
from you guys uh because i'm just sort
of unsure where to go over myself so
about 25 right now i am 25 i'm sorry i'm
25. i have a job making about 70k i have
a bachelor's i have a master's degree
um
and so i
started i just you know i just finished
my degree and then i you know started my
job and yeah the money is okay it's
pretty good but i have about 40 000 in
that savings account i just saved you
know because i have like sort of a lower
paying job but i live at home so i was
just saving all the money that i was
making from it and so now i just have
about 40 000 just sitting in a bank
account and i just don't know what to do
with it
okay so let me recap you make 70 000 a
year you're 25 years old and you have 40
000 in liquid cash in a savings account
okay uh and are you following the baby
steps
no sir
okay do you have any debt currently
i have eight thousand dollars of a
student loan debt that's about no
interest
it's just there well as of today you do
not have a student loan because you're
gonna pay that off as soon as you get
off the phone uh out of that forty
thousand dollars in savings which puts
you at 32 left and so what you're going
to do there you obviously already have
the starter emergency fund that's baby
step one uh and once you pay off the
student loan you don't have a payment in
the world you said you're living with
family right
yeah also planning to just like move out
in like you know five six months
great well that savings account is going
to be a huge help a great buffer uh as
you move out and start life on your own
you've got a great income at 25 making
70k you don't have any payments at this
point once we pay off that student loan
as soon as you get off the phone and
you're gonna have a fully funded
emergency fund with that money left over
is that right
that's that's correct yeah that's
correct wonderful so it sounds like
that's gonna put you at baby step four
where you're investing 15 percent of
your income into retirement uh if you've
got a 401k with your job that's a great
place to start you can open up a roth
ira get in touch with one of our
smartbester pros at ramseysolutions.com
they can walk you through all of that
but you're doing great man i want to
encourage you that's fantastic ricardo
correct money you're going to be debt
free in about oh i don't know 12 to 15
minutes or less i'm so pumped wow call
back do a dead free screen that'll be
fun oh there we go
so good do what he said ricardo it's
gonna change your life you're on a great
path all right folks
don't move more ramsey show coming right
up
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsey show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to jump
in
our scripture of the day hebrews 11 6 it
is impossible to please god without
faith anyone who wants to come to him
must believe that god exists and that he
rewards those who sincerely
seek
him our quote today from dale carnegie
much of the best work
of the world has been done against
seeming
impossibilities and that is absolutely
true good stuff there triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
let's go to fairbanks alaska jasmine
joins us there jasmine how can we
help hi um thank you for taking my call
um
so i am
a mom of two um
hey right on cue that was perfect how
did you time that did you practice that
um no he's just
he's a smarty pant
so
i'm i'm in 26 in october
and
i had my
daughter
when i was um i just i found out that i
was going to have her when i was like
21.
um so i spent most of my adult life
being mom
and um i've realized that i've kind of
lost myself and
i want to be in a position where we can
get that free and
provide the life that we want for our
kids
but i don't know
what i should be doing i don't know
where
you know what kind of job i should be
looking for or what i would even be good
at yeah
well let's start there
because when you say that
i don't know that you believe that
now i know you've been at home since 21
basically but before that you were
uh you were somebody who was involved in
high school maybe even did a little bit
of college or something and you are
talented
what would everybody say jasmine if i
interviewed them and said tell me what
jasmine always
did very well what came easy for jasmine
she didn't have to struggle it was easy
for her jasmine tell us what you're
actually really good at
um i
i don't know i mean
i like
interacting with people
okay i know you like it but i'm guessing
you're good at it too
right you're a good connector of people
like you connect and you you can make
conversation easy is that what you mean
yeah yeah do you understand people well
do you you find that you have high
compassion and high empathy
i think so yeah do you are you an advice
giver tell me more what would people say
you're having a hard time talking about
yourself so i want you to go to a place
where you go well ken here's what
everybody else would tell you because
you know that's what they would tell me
because you've heard him say it to you
where are you really gifted when it
comes to people
um say it now jasmine listen to me i've
done this many many times and you're not
the first person to struggle to say
something nice about themselves
but while you were pausing you were
actually deleting or trying to edit
answers i know this is true am i right
jasmine
yes then i want you to say what was on
your mind jasmine what would people tell
me that you're really good at when it
comes to people or anything else now say
it
um
empathy
compassion
maybe a thanksgiving
really all right real quick when's the
last time you gave somebody advice
that wasn't your little your little one
you remember you don't have to tell me
the whole story just do you remember yes
or no
yes
do you remember how they reacted when
you were done giving them advice
yeah how'd they react
he kind of
hung his head down and said yeah you're
probably right
yeah and so they walked away knowing man
jasmine hit me right between the eyes
that's what i needed to hear how did you
feel when when he left
um
that i was hopeful that things would get
better for him but it felt good too
though didn't it to say what needed to
be said
yeah yeah
yeah okay so we would say confidently
now jasmine that you're good at people
skills you get a lot of good people
skills yes
yes and we could also say that you like
working with people yes
yes yeah so jasmine now you gotta say
what's on your mind jasmine if you knew
you couldn't fail and i fast forward any
qualifications and i guarantee that you
would not
suck in the job what would you try
without having to commit the rest of
your life to it you're only 26 what
would you try in the people business
what would you do who would you help
um
i would really want to try
working with um like some kind of crisis
pregnancy center and i want you to tell
me why because there's a part of your
story on this there's something deep
here this is your why you're getting
ready to reveal
why
why there
um
because
i
you know found out i was gonna have a
baby a week before i turned 21
and
i felt like my
whole life was gonna be over
um and
i
wasn't married to
her dad um you know it was a
casual kind of relationship and
i didn't think that i could do it
yeah
and somebody spoke into your life
yeah
and as a result you kept that beautiful
little baby
so you want to do that for somebody else
yeah yeah
so jasmine
that's what you need to be doing
you need to figure out the path forward
there
so we just look at okay
i want to
work at a crisis pregnancy center or a
non-profit that that is going to meet
these young moms right where they are
and i know that i can help because i've
been there i know exactly what they're
thinking i know exactly what they're
feeling
and that matters deeply to me so we ask
ourselves what does it take to do that
what qualifications do you need well you
may not need a whole lot of
qualifications at all just to get in and
maybe work at the reception desk right
uh or or in some position that doesn't
require a counseling degree but let's
say we get you in there right and the
babies are getting a little bit older
and you're working your way back in and
you're falling in love with this mission
that is moving your heart to tears right
now and then all of a sudden you go okay
in two or three years i can get a degree
or i can finish a degree and then i can
get my counseling i can cash flow my way
through we get out of debt first and i
know that in my early 30s i could be
counseling i could be a full-time
therapist or counselor helping women
that have gone through all kinds of
stuff
so it's just about getting yourself back
out there and sticking your toe in the
water but i think your homework
assignment is to find any crisis
pregnancy center you can in fairbanks or
or government agencies that work with
these young ladies you get where those
women are that you want to help do you
understand
yes and you just go help them and you
get a paycheck helping them and then you
get your feet wet and then you get you
kind of get you see legs a little bit
right you begin to see oh here's a path
here here's a path over there but
jasmine that's what you're supposed to
do
you know and i know it don't
we yeah
jasmine i'm going to tell you something
i think you're an amazing young lady
and i think that the pain and the
uncertainty and all the stuff that you
went through and that you've overcome
see that's that's not even about you
anymore it's about young women that
you're going to come in contact with
and i'm really proud of you thank you
for sharing that intimate story with us
jasmine you are an absolute rock star
um hang on the line uh kelly i would
like to give her a copy of my book the
proximity principle which is all about
connections now that she knows what she
wants to do this is what she needs to do
let's give her that jasmine read the
book engage with it tell you exactly
what to do chapter by chapter the people
you need to be around the places you
need to be in and opportunities are
going to knock on your door
wow george that was powerful ken is
there anything more special than helping
someone reveal their purpose
well not to not not to me i mean i'm
just that happens to be my thing i think
a lot of people out there that get you
know a great charge out of doing
something else and that's that's the
unique kind of nature of what what we
get to do here um but that's really
powerful stuff i i would just say this
to anybody else out there that connected
to jasmine's story and you're going hmm
i don't really know what i want to do
well what we did there was just take her
to her heart
what moves her heart who are the people
you want to help why do you want to help
them and it's always got a deep personal
connection wow really powerful i'm
inspired by her hey man she's amazing
hey i enjoyed it this was great george
first of all many times together thank
you pal you were great ben hill our
producer today thank you benny
and of course our associate producer
call screener really she keeps us all in
line
kelly daniel and america
gotta thank you you're why we do the
show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
you